college students at csn and unlv getting
ready to walk back into class this
morning many walking in with the hopes
of a career in hospitality we have a few
of those jobs here in the valley but
before you get any job of course you
have to be interviewed and that's where
csn's coyote closet comes in candace
charles is live this morning inside the
closet at the csn north las vegas campus
candace good morning to you tell us more
good morning youtube good morning folks
yes you gotta dress for success if
you're trying to get the job you want
you come here you get the classes done
but you need to be ready and prepared
when you walk into the interview and
that's what the coyote closet is all
about helping with you guys for this and
look you know what i look prepared
already and you know i needed a place
like this to kind of help me i think it
would be helpful for me as well and i'm
joined by shawn torre who is the campus
life coordinator who sits here in the
coyote classes to help folks out tell us
how this works so the coyote closet if a
student comes to me like hey we need
professional clothing i have an
interview coming up or i just don't have
any suits in general they can come here
they check in with the qr code right
there that's how we actually able to
keep record
so three pieces is very particular you
can get three different suits you can
mix and match three different shirts
with pants or
ties ties and socks we do provide socks
new socks by the way that's awesome
and uh they're very different exclusive
so you can come once a semester
but that's because you know we have so
many students we want to make sure that
we have enough for students in there as
well right right now this is one of the
services that you guys provide beside
games in the clothes what else do you
get through this service so the other
services we have a food pantry called
the coyote cupboard and students can
actually come in twice a week to get
food and this is not only just grabbing
goats for themselves this is food
actually to provide for their families
as well awesome awesome i wanted to show
you really quickly nate i know you're
watching this
this awesome potash i put together now
it's very simple to do right so like i
wear bow ties real bow ties as well but
then there was a time where i didn't so
i would have to turn my ties into bow
ties right yes so you go here and make
little loops and these are certain
things that i teach the students as well
tricks and i also teach in the parents
awareness class i call it appearance
awareness because it's not only about
how you dress but your character as well
right absolutely absolutely now we don't
want to give it all away but this is
what's a very cool tie i know nate would
love to wear something like this he's
going to show it to us in a few minutes
here but this is one of the services you
can get when you come on down to the
coyote closet and of course classes
start today you guys you can find out
more details look at that isn't that so
cool that's so awesome
yeah you know i knew that nate would
love this
thank you so much john i appreciate it
again classes kick off today and of
course you can find out more details by
going to
csn.edu for now on candice charles eight
news now love that he's all dialed in
the bow tie is proper yes i love it and
it's so important to have that that
opportunity for students absolutely
especially the growth at csn candace as
you just saw you know when you're
transitioning from the college life to
the real world while you're still in the
college you gotta get a dress for
success
candace thank you that's awesome let's
talk web